Bonjour à tous,
vous avez déjà la date dans vos agendas,
il faut qu'elle soit maintenant
dans tous les agendas.
Cette date, c'est le
29 septembre au 1ᵉʳ octobre.
Pourquoi ?
Pour l'Université de Rentrée du Mouvement Démocrate !
Où ça ?
À Guidel, en Bretagne !
C'est un temps fort
pour notre famille politique,
de se retrouver tous ensemble
pour débattre de l'avenir de notre pays,
des grands enjeux
structurants à l'échelle internationale,
et donc aussi de parler
d'Europe bien évidemment.
Les élections européennes
sont dans moins de 300 jours.
C'est capital pour nous,
qui sommes fondamentalement européens,
de pouvoir
débattre d'énormément de sujets.
Bien évidemment,
la guerre en Ukraine,
le changement climatique,
l'intelligence artificielle,
les enjeux sociaux.
Donc, rendez-vous
dès le 29 septembre à Guidel.